here's a little interesting video about
human nature this was making the rounds
as people have been talking about
reparations again we found you know
people always say to me Dave you always
say these good things about Florida and
never say anything about Florida that's
negative can't you find someone in
Florida who's not making sense and put
them on the program and then this
morning Phoenix said Dave you should
watch this video here's a hearing that
they had in Tampa Florida over the last
couple days uh where a uh they were
talking about reparations and they were
letting people come up and explain why
they should get reparations and exactly
how much they should get here's uh one
such gentleman
all this nonsense homelessness and all
this other garbage y'all talk about
police violence and all this stuff don't
nobody care about that
don't nobody real care about that we
care about our reparations and we have
to put white people on notice
that we want our reparations that our
four parents and us we didn't work for
free and underpaid and all this nonsense
and the white folks get away with it and
they talk about the great city they're
building no we want our reparations
three million dollars per person
three million dollars per person right
here in this city that's the only thing
black people got to care about all this
other little nonsense y'all talk about
we do not care about
guys we're not going to talk about the
nonsense like you know homelessness in
our cities decaying and everything else
we want three million in cash I like how
he just came up with that number was
that based on anything but it's such a
misunderstanding look I don't need to
make it about this one guy I think he's
an example of how people's priorities
have been bungled like if you want to
help this guy's life like let's say this
guy lives I'm assuming he lives in Tampa
this was a Tampa related event so if if
there's an area of Tampa let's say that
is economically depressed that he would
like to be fixed up a little bit or
they'd like less crime or whatever there
are ways to go about doing that you
could actually do things like cut taxes
which would then invite new businesses
to come in at the same time you know you
can't get upset when a Starbucks comes
in this is one of the bigger problems
you know like a Starbucks will go to
Harlem and people say they're
gentrifying and it's like no you should
want Starbucks to be there because once
Starbucks is there you get another store
in another store in another store that's
sort of a whole separate issue but the
the point is they've confused people so
that they're not upset about the actual
things going in on in their life and in
their Community right at this very
moment like crime and drugs and
homelessness and all that they just want
the cash and again
it's a fundamental misunderstanding of
human psychology if you think if you
give to that man and everyone else you
give them one million dollars two
million dollars three million dollars it
doesn't matter that then it's going to
wrap it up oh okay we're good to go we
signed off on the document guys no more
racism and generations behind us they'll
uh they'll be cool with this no the
generations behind them will call them
sellouts because they didn't get enough
cash that's how this thing works but the
point is the promises of reparation that
the Democrats have been offering for so
long are complete and utter BS
[Music]
thank you